what's up elimination it's Evan I am
back for another episode of how to get
to 1 million subscribers on YouTube in
this series I document my journey on how
I'm getting to 1 million subscribers and
giving you my advice my tips answering
your questions along the path I'm almost
there we are getting close and so this
series is gonna end pretty soon but I'm
excited to be here at least while we
have it going today I'm gonna talk about
something really important
I'm talking about thumbnails I'm talking
about titles how to get people to click
through on them and how important they
are to making a youtube channel take off
in previous episodes I've talked about
the importance of uploading frequently
and then I've hopefully hit that I
pounded that into your head enough I
think it's the single most important
thing that you can do as a youtuber
right now if you want to get your videos
ranked produce content daily get to
daily or at least make it your goal to
go daily if you need to be convinced as
to why I go back and watched all the
other episodes in your series and you'll
find out today the only talk about
thumbnails I want to talk about titles
I'm gonna look at my channels an example
some of the things that I'm using that's
really helped me I'm gonna compare my
channel to value tainment a friend of
mine Patrick Reed David and Oprah's
channel and I'm also going to give you a
tool that I use consistently that has
really helped optimize the performance
of my titles and tags let's do it so
first of all I wanna do a quick update
as to where I was as the last video
actually don't know where I was as of
the last video we can flash a big number
on the screen of how many subscribers I
had as of the last video but it's been a
great month for us this is my channel on
social blade and last month we had what
last 30 days 50 53 54 thousand
subscribers we're at 9 almost 9 19 right
now quoted my social blade and you could
see down here it was our best month ever
four views eight point eight million our
best month ever subs sixty-two
sixty-three thousand almost it was a
really really good month and we're
closing in on that million gap the last
video is I compared myself to Gary Vee
and ty Lopez I predicted I get two
million before Gary Vee if you look at
his channel now you could see he's at
he's at age 65 with sixteen hundred a
day
I'm at 9:19 with seventeen eighteen
hundred a day
so I thought he was gonna pass me let me
show you his graph see look Gary was
taking off and I thought he was gonna
pass me around here but then he started
tanking and he took August off and he
left it to his team and they kind of
dropped the ball to be honest and now
he's back and starting to do well again
but I don't think he's gonna catch it so
little disappointing in Tai Lopez you
never know what tires gonna do if you
look at his updates he's almost at a
million 996 is getting close but his sub
numbers are really low you can see here
you know he had he's had these spikes
and then he goes massively down you know
and in this month here he only had 402
subscribers and then 292 subscribers and
then 6.27 thousand so he really focuses
on advertising when he advertises he
gets more subs and growth than when he
doesn't advertise he loses subscribers
so we'll see I don't know if I'll beat
him to a million but we'll see what
happens
so today's topic thumbnails and titles
why they are important let's just
quickly look at this this is my stats
for the past 30 days so past 30 days
69 68 million minutes of watch time 8.3
million views look at this this is what
I've been talking about this whole
series
you know 5678 videos that we put on the
channel not all of them are live but
that's a lot of work daily consistent
content I guarantee you it's gonna help
this is where I think a lot of people
make a mistake so look at where my
traffic is coming from and I encourage
you to go look at yours and you'll find
that it's probably something really
really similar most of my traffic this
purple chunk here comes from suggested
videos this red one is browse features
and then third is YouTube search so this
green is YouTube search too many people
optimized for YouTube search you're
thinking of this as Google right in
Google when you're when you have a
website you're trying to rank it you're
thinking SEO you're thinking keywords
you're thinking how do I get my video
ranked which is a very SEO kind of
website way to think about things it's
not how YouTube works if you are trying
to optimize for search as your primary
indicator you are going to lose search
does not drive a ton of traffic right
9.5 percent of my watch time where 77
percent come from these two so the
purple one
videos that's the videos along the side
so if you look at a typical video that's
this this is where most of your views
will come it's going to come from the
suggested related videos after somebody
watches a video so either at the end of
this video where those if I go to an end
this video for example a mute so I go to
the end so yes it videos are gonna be
these right right here at the end and
these down the side that suggested Vida
that's where most of your traffic is
gonna come from and then this red one
here is browse features that's going to
come from the YouTube homepage so here
if I go to youtube.com whatever people
see here on the homepage and from the
subscription feed so if you click on
subscriptions here you lead to here
these are people that subscribed to and
you can see it here and so this is where
most of your traffic will come from so
the key is how do I stand out how do you
stand out along this side right you need
to have titles and you need to have a
thumbnail that really really grabs their
attention now I'm fortunate that a lot
of these are going to be my own on my
own videos but why would somebody click
on your video with your thumbnail
instead of somebody else's what's gonna
help make you stand out and I'm gonna
share my strategies to help do that and
the same thing applies here like of all
these things he's recommended you know
the other places that I subscribe to the
description feed like why would I pick
this video to watch instead of this
video right a lot of it it could be the
greatest content in the world but if you
don't have a great thumbnail and you
don't have a great title this is gonna
be really hard to get the views that you
need and so that's what it really really
really really really want to focus on
with today's video so for those of you
who are focused on SEO and worried about
keywords and tags and descriptions and
all that stuff it helps it's definitely
important but not as important as you
think we're much much much more
important is this 77 percent stop
playing this 9.5% game and again go
check your channel like prove me wrong
go check your stats on your channel and
see if you're getting the number one
source of traffic as YouTube search then
keep doing what you're doing great go
for it go for SEO but if these two
the ones that are coming up then the way
to win here is you need to have better
titles and better thumbnails so let's go
through some examples I'm gonna look at
my friend Patrick be David from value
team and he's got a great channel around
entrepreneurship growing pretty quickly
almost four hundred thousand subs
Congrats Patrick some of the things that
I want to talk about for what to look
for in a thumbnail and a title first you
want to make sure it's
attention-grabbing
second you want to make sure it looks
good when it's small and third you want
to make sure that it's recognizable and
that it's your so people can immediately
tell that it is yours so let's look at
Patrick's channel is an example
attention-grabbing
I think Patrick does actually a really
good job way better than than most
people on YouTube in terms of
attention-grabbing thumbnails you look
at it he has fun pictures he has serious
pictures he has famous people like Andy
Roddick on here he's got you know
cartoons that stand out globe's he has
things that kind of draw you in some
things I would think about making sure
that people are really recognizable so
for example Andy Roddick you know you
see it in the title but if you look at
that face you may not know that that's a
Mirotic because he has that visor on now
that's an actual clip from the interview
I think that he did with him but I would
look at maybe doing a different face so
that you know instantly that that's any
erotic same thing down here with Wayne
Gretzky it's not the most recognizable
picture of Wayne Gretzky so you might
pick something that's a little more easy
to recognize that it's him but for the
most part they're pretty
attention-grabbing
right it's easy to see they stand out so
it that's a big win for for Patrick some
of them like this one I don't know how
attention-grabbing that one is but on
the whole it's pretty attention got me
like he's got he's here with a sword and
the shield's like if I saw this in a sea
of this right it would stand out and a
good test is what do you pay attention
to yourself like go to your own
subscription feed and see which
thumbnail do you pay most attention to
what would you click on what's relevant
what looks good and which ones are you
ignoring and from your own test you can
see okay you know what I totally ignored
this thing mongoose uses snake as a
swing I don't know why that's in my
subscriptions but anyway like what I
don't even know what that is my eyes go
right past
I'm looking at the faces of these other
people and so use your own example to
see what your eyes are drawn to and then
you can model some of that for your own
channel so packages are really good job
on the attention-grabbing next is what
looks good small so this is one size but
it's going to get even smaller when you
get to your actual videos if I go back
here and I compare it to here this is a
little bit bigger than the ones that are
shown here not much but a little bit
bigger and it makes a difference and so
if somebody's watching this video and
they're gonna see down the side what's
coming up is this enough to understand
on a really small scale what it's all
about and make me want to click and so
one of the things that I'm talking to my
editor a lot about is I mean we need to
make the font bigger we need to make the
font bigger because we need to be able
to see it small they won't see this
Johnny and thumbnail that has all this
detail they're gonna see it this size so
it has to be visible build your
confidence keep going productive habits
they're easy to read ever look to
Patrick's a lot of them are pretty good
you know three toxic habits to avoid in
life something like this so might be
little bit hard to read when it's
smaller something like this where you
can't really read like the red on the
block can be hard to read it's hard to
see that that's that's how Amazon
destroyed a six billion dollar retail
giant smaller that might be even hard to
read you don't want to make it hard for
people understand what you're all about
but for the most part he does a pretty
good job right join the military or go
to college also one thing quickly guys
to make sure there's always gonna be a
little time stamp on top of the video so
you want to make sure that the time
stamp does not cover your title see you
like this one have it take your business
global you can still read that that's
global but it's gonna be hard to see
because it's covered up so try not to
have text or anything that people need
to read in the bottom right hand corner
of any of your thumbnails because it's
gonna limit the ability to read it and
then you won't get click throughs but
for the most part you can read some of
this stuff I just look at some of them
like this this one has a lot of text
case studies with the biz dogs so like
hard to read that you know how three
startups raise millions and lost it you
can't read the all because it's covered
and even that's a little tight on the
font but in general is pretty good like
something like this great stop making
excuses
good it's getting late every
entrepreneurs best friend so in general
I just want to make sure
it's easy to be able to read and then
recognizable there's five things that I
look at recognizable so we started off
with is it attention-grabbing
does it look good small and then is it
recognizable recognizable I look at
colors logo format personality in the
title so the goal here is if I've just
finished watching a value tainment video
or or Evan Carmichael video or on your
channel just finish watching your video
I want to easily know that this next
item about the watch is also from the
same creator if the thumbnails are
totally different and the titles are
totally different and there's no
consistency then it's hard for me to
know like maybe I love that video that
have been put up but I didn't know that
the next one is by him and so I'm not
going to click through and watch and so
if I look at Patrick's an example the
first one we look at is the colors so
Patrick is using yellow and red mostly
yellow red and white so there's some
consistency in a theme even more
consistency would make it easier for
people understanding of this his channel
the logo you see on pretty much all the
videos who he's got this little logo
here some of them they're on some of
them they're not you know let's see wow
this one doesn't have it on but for the
most part they have it on what I would
do is try to put it in a consistent spot
so like this is perfect top right top
right like get this out of here move the
top right top right top right top right
so that I know every time it's top right
I see that icon it's a patrick be david
value taming video i want to watch that
thing when it's in the middle or on the
side or not on it at all then people
don't know that it's your video again
watch out do not put it in the bottom
right-hand corner it's going to get
covered up and you won't see it so
patrick does a pretty good job without
is either bottom left or top right but I
love this positioning whether it's white
or red or yellow I would keep it to
probably two variations but still having
it be at the top in every single video
so it's easy to see and I know that's a
value tainment video I love the one I
just watched
I don't know watch the next one as well
next one is format and this is where we
start looking at fonts and colors and
where we're putting the text and how
we're putting the pictures so Patrick
uses probably about the same font each
time some of them he might customize
like military that's fine in college so
you're using like a military font and a
college kind of font it's pretty good so
it's it's almost always caps right the
numbers might might stand out whether
it's doing three three three so that's
pretty good if you're using different
fonts each time and you see this on a
lot of youtube channels every font is
totally different
every thumbnail is totally different so
if I just finished watching your video
and it's really great I can't tell it
the next video is yours so I'm not gonna
click through again we want people to
click here right or after they watch a
video where's my video here right I want
to be able to click through and know
that this video that's coming up is also
yours so we talked about colors we
talked about Logan we talked about
format next is personality this works
really well when you have a business and
a YouTube channel around yourself so
patrick has it around himself the more
that he's in the thumbnails the easier
it's gonna be for people to click on it
now Patrick is in almost every thumbnail
which is awesome unless he has I guess
this biz dog guy doing a series
Patrick's in pretty much every single
thumbnail here maybe this one's a little
bit different but even the biz dog is
here and the biz doc is here and the biz
dog is here so now he's building up a
brand around the biz dog as well but
looking at this video if I watched you
know you're only five necks away from
being a millionaire great I see Patrick
here I see Patrick here I'm gonna click
on that I see Patrick here I'm gonna
click on that right so if your
personality driven Channel but putting
your face on the thumbnails each time
makes it easy for people to know that
it's your video if you're not a
personally driven Channel than having
similar formats right go back to the
other points that we're talking about
and then the last thing you do is in the
title you could you could look at
putting the series name in the title put
in the channel in the title putting
something putting the hashtag in the
title something in the title that makes
people know that this is your video so
that they click from one they go to the
next they know that that's yours
so that's how it breaks down in
Patrick's Channel let's go to so here's
an example of Patrick's video so I
finished watching this video great
Patrick awesome free toxic habits that's
amazing I learned
talk to habits hopefully not gonna do it
here's what shows up and again use your
own test like look at these thumbnails
where are you gonna click on next are
you gonna click on this so can you can
read that title that's pretty good but
at the top you can't like what does that
say
so daily habits of successful people
what is that logo and what does it say
above it it looks like weekly motivation
presents I don't know and I'm a fan of
Brian although this isn't his channel
this is jjp motivation but that
thumbnail could be better this one Dave
asked retrain your brain like that could
be it's hard to read the white on a
light background that could be better
with Luis and Luis is another friend
like where is the branding I want to see
the school of greatness branding on here
I want to make it I want to know that
this is Louis's video talks at Google
you know it's just a picture Tim Ferriss
which is great but I don't know who made
it let's see let's go down to more value
tainment so value man shows up here
great thumbnail showing money on a
thumbnail is always good what's missing
here is where's the branding right
where's the logo how do I know that
that's value tainment it's great to see
Patrick on it that's what helps cells
that look at that money point that's
amazing scrolling down here's some more
from Patrick look at how easy it is to
read this 12 mistakes I made my first
years in entrepreneur perfect logo at
the top great easy to know that's
Patrick here's another one just missing
a logo but a has Patrick on it has a
text on it this is where the more it's
consistent like if I watch this video as
an example this is where the the pattern
of your users becomes really really
really important if this shows up in my
subscription feed right and I really
like this video then I'm going to start
looking for other videos that look like
this and so even though this video is on
the same Channel I may not associate it
with Patrick because Patrick's not in
this but he isn't this the logos here
but it's not here
there's a big number and then huge text
and there's big text but no number so
like if I finish watching this I may not
know that this is also Patrick's video
and so I may not click on it now this
down here is an example right 11 skills
looks the same as this so there's
probably high click-through rate from
this to this and then I'm going to be
looking for other videos that look like
this so it's important to have some
variety on your thumbnails but also make
sure that people don't get confused
between
one thumbnail on another thumbnail so
the more you can have consistent
elements the easier you keep people on
your channel flowing from one video to
the next let's get a look at Oprah as an
example here now so this is Oprah's
Channel Oprah has 1.4 million
subscribers and obviously leverages her
brand a lot let's go through the three
things attention-grabbing looks good
small and recognizable so
attention-grabbing I don't know okay
like are those thumbnails emotional if
you saw that you know if you saw this is
that attention-grabbing if you saw that
is this attention-grabbing you know this
is iyanla Vanzant she's recognizable you
may know her so that might be more
attention grabbing Vera Wang like is
that the best picture of her is that
attention-grabbing you know just use
your own test I don't know that any of
these really pass the attention-grabbing
test at least for me and so this
wouldn't be one that I want to model
maybe this like what's happening here
she looks like she's shoving him into
the wall I don't know what's happening
that that's a little different but again
does it pass your own test for
attention-grabbing
second looks good small so remember it's
going to be smaller than this so
something that has a lot of detail isn't
going to look really good small
something like this where it's hard to
know what's happening so she's sitting
there talking to somebody who's out of
famous person do I need to know who that
is like this is about a Yan la it's in
the it's in here but I don't know that
that's the young about looking at her
and the side profile and it's gonna be
even smaller so all those little details
will be lost when it's when it's really
small so I don't know how many of these
really good look good small and then is
it recognizable you know if you saw any
of these would you know that it's
Oprah's Channel so they do a great job
in the branding of Iyanla fix my life as
an example so if I see this I'm looking
for that for future one so I know that
this is all part of the same series
because it says Iyanla fix my life and
same thing for the released released
released right easy to see that that's
hers the own that's more symbolic with
Oprah Winfrey's Channel so I'm thinking
that's for sure an Oprah Winfrey video
this logos a little bit hard to see you
can see the Oprah Winfrey the logo I
mean the signature you can't really you
know if you just saw that you mean not
recognize it it could be it could it
could stand out a lot more this little
white shading here it could be
different so that this local pops a lot
stronger this I can't even see what it
is loving something wrong loving you see
I don't know right like that's not good
and so I would recommend having
something because Oprah has such a big
name you may not understand what
released means may not recognize that
with her but if I had a little own at
the top right oh that's an Oprah video
like how much this video only had 343
views right she's got 1.5 million
subscribers in this video had 343 views
if that video up here had this own logo
that really popped out I guarantee you
this video would get more views just
because of the power of branding people
see this [ __ ] showing up again they see
this showing up on the side and they
don't know that it's hers
and so they don't click on it nobody
watches it same thing this entire series
and you can look at it by series - like
this series you know 401 views it's not
getting a lot it's not doing well and
part of it is the explosion like maybe
the video itself isn't very good I don't
know I haven't watched it but if I can't
tell that that's an Oprah Winfrey video
that I'm not gonna watch it and so she's
gonna really lose traction momentum on
that if you look at what I do a lot of
my videos follow a similar format where
we have somebody's picture on there
right and then bold text all caps on the
left and then we have our logo on every
video in the series logo so you know
patrick has his logo almost on every
video we talked about that right in the
top right Oprah only has the series logo
but not the channel logo I recommend
trying to find a place to do both so
some of these we don't have a series
logo for like my book sample video I
don't have a series logo this is a new
one we're looking at so we don't have a
logo yet
but for the flushed out series that have
an ongoing theme or in spresso our top
10 the end vibes you know you look at
each one you see the plane that seven
Carmichael and then you see the logo you
know what the series is so having
similar fonts right it's always white
it's always orange the text is always on
the left side for the most part and it's
just easier to know that this is my
channel and so you watch one video
you're more likely to watch the next
video because you saw
all this stuff right you see this it
looks a lot like this and it looks a lot
like this it looks a lot like this and
this and this and even this it's not
that big a difference and so people get
used to if you watch Louie CK and that's
the first video you've seen on my
channel and you like it and you see
something like this that looks like it's
same format you know this is my channel
because it looks similar and so you're
much more likely to click through on
this enjoy that and then click on the
next one and then eventually subscribe
to the channel and so you really really
really want to make sure that people can
tell that it's yours so the colors are
fine the logos you can tell the
formatting is pretty simple personality
is something for me I'm not in every
video right so Patrick Lee David is on
more him of his videos than I am Oprah
is not on any of these videos but maybe
she's not inside them you know I'm like
if Oprah Rose interviewing Meryl Streep
Oprah should be here Oprah is
interviewing this person I don't know
what this person is but you know who
Oprah is so they would they should
definitely show her face I'm not in a
lot of the videos I'm doing the
introduction but it's mostly about louis
c.k or TD jakes and so i show their face
and their face also brings some
awareness of you know who what's in this
video and people know who these people
are so it's a way to get more people in
and then the title at the end of the
series will always put a hashtag with
the name of the series so this is an
answer press oh this is an espresso this
is a one rule you know this is this will
say top ten at the end of it and so it
helps people understand okay and
espresso an espresso top ten one rule
it's not the biggest factor the
thumbnails more important but having
that in the thumbnail can can play a
role again looking back at all these
things what we want to pay attention to
attention-grabbing thumbnail and title
it looks good small and it's
recognizable that is your so that if I
watch one of yours I know which future
ones are yours when they show up in my
feet those three things are really
really really critical and if you're
recognizable we're looking at colors
logo format personality and title you
can watch that video back again if you
want the breakdown again and finally
always use yourself as the asset test
you know if you saw your thumb then
would you click on it if you're looking
at my channel looking at this page these
are all my thumbnails
you look at this page what stands out to
you what would you click on would you
click on Tony Robbins cuz he's smiling
would you click on the rock because he's
serious would you click on me because
I'm pointing that stuff or if you look
at Patrick's channel would you click on
this because he's in you know this armor
he's got he's got his sword and shield
would you click on this because of the
blue background would you click on this
because you recognize Wayne Gretzky or
this because they see the jet plane in
the background like think about your own
patterns what you love clicking on and
then think how can I model that for my
own channel again looking back at the
analytics it's the most important thing
suggested videos and browse features
stop paying so much attention to search
it's ok but it's only 10 percent least
of my traffic pay attention to your
thumbnails and your titles spend more
time on your thumbnails and your titles
now I want to end off before getting the
questions by showing you a tool that I
use that helps me with my thumbnails and
my titles it's strong too buddy this is
part of their paid tool I forget how
much I'm on the most expensive platform
I forget what it is I think it's 50
bucks or something I'm not being
sponsored by this I just love using this
tool and I've given them feedback I want
to see this tool get more flesh there
there's a problem with YouTube and that
they don't allow you to split test it's
so weird this is such a data-driven
company but they don't allow you to
split test your results and so there's
no easy way to test one title against
another title to test one thumbnail
against another thumbnail and see which
one does better so the closest thing I
found to it is through to buddy and they
have a tool that allows you to test the
thumbnail the title the tags in the
description I don't care so much about
the tags in description we just test
thumbnail and title because that's
really what's going to help drive those
two metrics for the analytics so here's
an example this is our original Mark
Cuban top 10 rules we thought okay what
if we put Cuban yelling you could be a
more emotional and Mark Cuban picture
instead of a smiling happy Cuban what if
we had him looking at the text instead
of looking at the audience and see which
one does better and what to buddy does
is it I'll show one thumbnail for one
day so February 5th to show the original
or the variation and then the next day
it shows the original and so it shows
one version one day one version the next
day one version one day one version the
next day for 14 days until you get some
results now it's really important as
you're doing these tasks to make sure
picking an older video because if you
pick a brand-new video and you're doing
split test it's gonna be inaccurate data
because the first day of your launch you
should get way more views than the next
day and then it'll continue to trail
down and so trying to pick a video where
you're gonna get enough views right like
we're getting almost 500 views a day
average on this video so it's enough to
start testing if you only have three
views a day it's gonna be hard to get
good data on and also not something
that's so brand new that the initial
spike is really high so this lets us
test them now so our theory was a more
emotional thumbnail would allow people
to want to click on it more we were
wrong
right the original version of this video
I'll perform the variation this one is
better than this one and it's only by
15% it's not by 2,000 percent it's not a
massive difference but if you can
increase like if I extrapolate that
across my channel if I can increase my
views by 15% by just doing this it makes
a big difference and so you can test you
can test colors you can test pictures
you can test your logos you can test
different variations to see which one is
doing better so this is one test we did
right emotional picture versus smiling
happy picture this is my only happy
picture did better maybe I just have a
happier audience you know maybe somebody
else's audience there they're yelling
they're mean they're emotional they're
going on rants and this one would
perform better but for my audience this
one is better and I'm coming happy about
that to be honest
here's another test that we did let's
let's try to make our thumbnail even
better let's try a different version of
it let's make a sumed in picture of
cuban let's put the text on the
thumbnail instead of putting it just
Cubans 10 rules to the lesson from
inside well it didn't work right the
original version I'll perform the
variation by sixteen and a half percent
so this is no let's not do that ever
again right that is not the way to do it
this is still our winner and so I'm
happy when tests fail right most of the
tests will fail but if you find when it
starts to work then you can apply it
across the entire channel so we moved
the you know the top ten logo inside
instead of putting it there and just
this one didn't work out as well it's
fine another test we ran was now testing
the title so those were thumb
examples now let's esse title okay so we
know that having the top ten rules on
the video thumbnail itself that works
the best let's test the title so we have
Kevin O'Leary's top ten rules to success
as a title vs I'm never working for
someone again as our title well the very
issue one this time right and if you
look at all of our new videos now you'll
notice the top tens we don't have this
anymore in the in the title it's not
it's never the person's name top ten
roses success it always leads with a
quote because the quote we find
something that's attention-grabbing from
the video itself and we put it in and
more people click on it this is a very
SEO friendly search title this one is
not but this one is more attention
grabbing and on our newer ones we
usually capitalize almost every first
letter and then we find one word to do
all caps like I'm never never all caps
working for someone else
again again all caps exclamation point
after it that is more attention grabbing
than Kevin O'Leary's top ten was a
success and so that's what we do another
quick example is Mark Cuban so the
original one Mark Cuban this is perfect
this is a great example of what not to
do
right Mark Cuban interview is a search
term right if you type in and the way to
do this right you go to the top you go
Mark Cuban look mark you interview right
first suggested resolve that means a lot
of people are searching for that so hey
let's put that in our title right people
are searching for it let's go and look
at that in our title so here we put it
in and then Mark Cuban's top there was a
success compared to I'm working 24 hours
a day to kick your ass
this version I'm working 24 hours a to
kick your ass with the same thumbnail
outperformed by 17% the relevancy and
the attention-grabbing miss is more
important than the SEO value then
stuffing keywords in here it's more
important to have such an attention
gallery now again we modified this to
this would be capital W 12 hours day to
kick your ass like this whole thing
might be in caps exclamation point at
the end through the other test that
we've drawn we found that that works now
make sure one you're only testing one
thing at a time
don't test your thumbnail and your title
at the same time because you won't be
able to know what you're getting good
results for right you don't know if it's
a thumbnail
the title that's making a difference but
continue to test right keep testing
until you find the best format that
works for you and you're always trying
to beat your best right it's if you can
increase all your videos by 17% as soon
as we saw this right at work for O'Leary
it worked for Cuban now we're applying
across all of our videos as we do this
test right look at the jump how do you
make this jump how do you make that jump
in subscribers and views right how do
you make that jump well you got to make
better um the hell's a better better
titles right it's this testing that
allows me to do it and so again this is
from - buddy it's the only tool that I
know that allows you to do it I'm not
being paid by them I think this version
cost 50 bucks a month it's totally worth
it I mean I guess if you're brand new
just starting off this wouldn't be super
helpful because you only have enough
data to be able to really tell if a if a
result is working or not but once you
get some traction on your channel it's
worth it it's it's a no-brainer decision
as long as you're using it and always
running tests so I always have my team
testing this stuff out to see how we can
do the best job possible how we can get
the most results out of our thumbnails
our titles because you put so much work
into creating the content that you want
to make sure that it's getting the most
exposure possible so those are some
hacks that you can use to help you with
your thumbnails and your titles how is
that some good knowledge for you now I
want to get to the questions okay make
sure you're paying attention to your
thumbnails to your titles make them
attention-grabbing use yourself as a
proxy always to see would you click on
that and if you would you're on the
right track and then split test split
the split test using two buddy or maybe
you found another tool that works for
you if you do let me know I'll be doing
testing it out - lets get to your
questions some of the questions that
came in from last episode let's see what
we got - these are the questions in the
gary vee ty Lopez episode that I made
practical psychology I've said it before
I love this series and will watch every
single one let's race to a million happy
face thank you for the love man it's
been a lot of fun putting the series
together it's a ton of work doing - so
once we hit a million that's the end
we'll probably have one video left two
videos left depending and I'm excited to
have provided this value at least few
guys and it's great to hear that you're
enjoying next up mister gaming genius
how come
videos never pass 10,000 views and you
have nearly 900,000 subscribers that is
not true
lots of videos passed 10,000 views just
not all the videos passed 10,000 views
and that's what happens when you start
creating tons of consistent content you
got to see which videos are performing
the best for you keep that series and
start dumping the rest this is really
important this is super super super
super super super important
stop getting attached to how many views
any individual video gets if you produce
one video a week that single video will
get more views than if you're producing
a video a day but combined all those
videos that you're producing the day
will give you way more views in that
single video and what your goal is is to
have an impact right your goal is to
reach people your goal is to get your
message out there your goal is to get
exposure
you also get subscribers it goes to get
lots of views for your channel don't
make a single video channel views your
goal because you're gonna lose make the
channel growth the goal and if you look
at the size of my channel compare the
size of my channel to almost anybody
else who's that my same level so almost
a million subscribers now whatever I
said we're at 8 dates I don't remember
closing in no 9 9 something look at
other channels that have 900 thousand
subscribers and look at how many views
they have in their videos mine will
destroy them and that means I'm reaching
more people and so don't get too
attached it's the wrong metric don't get
too attached to how many people watch a
single video because you're gonna lose
the big game you're gonna lose the
bigger picture game I've been with a
reach a big audience and then that leads
to be able to sell your products get any
brand deals all that other stuff that
goes with building a YouTube channel
it's the biggest mistake that I see for
youtubers I can't tell you how many
youtubers I've met that that at one
point were bigger than me who complained
about and they didn't want to increase
their frequency because their views per
video were dropping and by paying
attention to that wrong metric other
people are blowing past them don't let
that be you pay attention to the right
things mister gaming genius next
Alexander Carmichael my sister
great tips thanks Evan I appreciate the
love Thank You Alexandra
next up what do we got Jen's Larsson
this is a great series I can't manage to
do one video per day but that of course
doesn't mean that I can't find it
interesting to see what you do what your
research tells you both with working
with the team and understanding YouTube
this is great info thank you for the
love and again for those of you who
can't do a video a day that's okay but
you want to make that your goal and
again think about if I'm making a video
a day what is what is my youtube channel
look like who do I have to have on my
team how I'm gonna be able to rule this
thing out so that I can make a video a
day it's okay if you can't get there yet
but have that part is your goal say how
do I get there and that's part of where
I want to get to whether it's this year
next year whatever it is you need to get
there you have to have a plan to get
there because it's something that
YouTube's heavily heavily heavily
prioritizes right now and if you can
even just double your volume for now and
then like if you're doing one a week to
go to two weeks it'll still make a big
difference and then three a week like
make it a realistic plan don't come from
the place that says I can never get to a
video a day you lose if that's your
mentality you lose it's like saying I'll
never make a million dollars I'll never
hit my big goal I'll never buy my dream
house I'll never create the business I
want like don't operate from a place of
scarcity instead of saying I can never
go out and do that I'm not saying that
this is you gens large semi senior
that's you but instead of hopping from
place of scarcity I can never do that
start asking yourself to how questions
how can I go do that when you figure
that out when you start asking your
brain that question you start getting
better answers when you just tell your
brain I can never do that then you're
right you never will do that you never
will get there so start asking how and
make it plain to get there whether
that's a three-month plan a six month
playing a two year playing whatever it
is that's your goal you want to get
there and it's possible for every
channel stop coming up with limiting
excuses that are holding you back it's
possible you can do it too I started by
myself I'm not a video editor I have
crappy video editing skills and I was
able to do it by building up a team
slowly right I didn't just jump to three
videos a day you can get there even
faster because you realize the
importance I didn't know how important
it was so you can get there faster than
I did you can get there faster than
others who aren't paying a
to this you can get there faster you can
go a faster channel than people who are
more skilled than you better on camera
create better content than you
you can pass by them because you are
hacking the algorithm better than they
are so put it on your plan let's see it
happen
congratulations Evan do you know how the
algorithm of YouTube interprets
scheduled uploads like if you upload
seven videos on one day but schedule
them throughout the week and make one
video with a public keep the rest
private I think that's okay I don't
I mean I don't have all the data on that
but it's what we do you know we won't
schedule usually a week in advance
usually were scheduled in a couple days
in advance but I haven't seen any
difference when we've scheduled four
days in advance versus putting it up
live and on the one day I think it's
much more about when the video goes
public then when it's created or when
it's uploaded and put private or
schedule so I just focus on getting the
videos when they go public making that
happen so if you publish you know month
in advance and you schedule them all out
I think you're okay
Estevan Lopez hi when you say you killed
the series do you mean you delete them
regards and thanks for teaching your
knowledge esta Ben no I don't I don't
delete videos ever it doesn't really
help like if you had a bad video and you
delete it it doesn't change the metrics
on your channel from everything that
I've seen and so you might as well just
keep it up when I say I killed the
series it just means I'm not making any
more of that series that's the end
I keep whatever is up was up when I
showed you my screen shall we have five
thousand something videos a lot of those
are from series that we cancelled as
well and they stay up and some people
still see them and it still helps drive
some traffic and awareness for your
channel but it just means I'm not going
to make more of them in the future I
don't recommend deleting the video
unless it's something that you know you
got a takedown notice on or you're just
not proud of it anymore or you've
changed and you don't you don't feel
passionate about that video anymore you
don't like it you know a lot of my
earlier videos I think I suck in the
earlier videos like my first videos but
people still watch them and it's good to
see the progress in my opinion like to
see me nervous and shy and awkward and
trying to make good videos at the
beginning I think it's part of the
journey so I wouldn't delete videos
really if I meant because the first ones
would be embarrassing just maybe you
said something that you
not proud of maybe something you don't
want your kids to see you know your
future kids your future grandkids and so
that's why I would delete it but from an
algorithm perspective once it's up
doesn't really make a difference next up
sim land Evan has been the underdog this
entire time waiting in the background
and now pouncing for the kill garyvee
beware and the me versus Gary B thing
has been a fun thing it's a little it's
a little disappointing now a little sad
because it's basically over I'm hoping
Gary comes back on really strong and
crushes it so that it's a it's a race
two million again when I passed him the
first time it was a good hey look we're
having Gary B and then it was who's
gonna get to 1 million first and I
thought he was gonna beat me and so like
yes good competition I love it let's
let's competition makes you go harder
right makes you faster and then it you
know August came and he was gonna go
away and his team was gonna take over
the can there's gonna go downhill so I
don't know we'll see I hope he comes
back on strong there's also nobody next
like this is a challenge for me in that
the next milestone is 10 million I guess
2 million or 5 million but 10 million is
the next real milestone and it's it's
it's not happening next year maybe
that's the only belief of mine right
like how do I get the 10 million next
year go to adjust my own mindset but
with our current numbers is not
happening anytime soon and there's
nobody above me that I really care about
like it's great that Oprah's at 1.5 or
whatever she was at but I know it
doesn't
she's on the entrepreneur space there's
nobody really ahead of me that it's like
okay next person network am I going up
against even in a fun way
the good news is though I just love to
work right like it's fun to have a goal
to shoot for and it's fun to have people
to kind of go up against and push you
but if that was the only reason why I
like if you're only doing your business
to chase this goal down you're gonna
ultimately fail because once you reach a
goal you know it's like you don't know
what to do next I guess you said another
goal but you need to have it meaningful
if you're only kind of jumping between
milestones you're never gonna have
success where you have to actually enjoy
the work like really those goals are
great but I like the work like I like
the day-to-day I like making videos for
you guys like being the comments I love
the work itself so I don't need to have
that external thing pushing me I would
just want to make better videos
next up beautifully different 86 I've
been on YouTube for almost a year now
congratulations I struggled with just
one video a week I do makeup videos and
haul videos I also talk about life with
disability and other health problems
that's great just keep putting out
content everybody struggles with making
videos like if it's important to you and
you put in time to make it good there's
a struggle like nothing great ever comes
without a great struggle it was super
easy to do stuff you get bored and you
don't want to do it anymore you could
put out a crappy video every day if you
wanted to hey here's what I bought five
minutes put it up but you have standards
and you want to make it good right and
so the struggle makes you better and so
it will be a struggle like expect
anything good in your life anything good
in business to come with a struggle I
think it's part of the process I
struggle every day on my youtube channel
to make things even better and I love
the struggle right like you thrive in
the struggle the struggle makes you
stronger
the struggle helps build your foundation
and so don't just look for the easy way
out right like this hacks right like
this video might give you some hacks to
make things go a little bit easier which
is fine but there's still a lot of real
work that goes behind it right like the
hacks are the extra 20% but the 80%
comes from
still what did I say to be in the video
these are great strategies to help you
but the number one most important thing
is still make daily content and what
that is gonna be a struggle so I feel
you like I'm empathetic I the struggle
is real the struggle is real for me
everyday even though I have my team
right like we're struggling to get it
going the quality of every video has to
go up the test a new series has to go up
it's a struggle don't get beaten down by
the struggle the struggle makes you
stronger you got to enjoy the struggle
if you're gonna have success as an
entrepreneur next up the collective
galue hi Evan thank you very soon my
comment I really appreciate it legend
join I've been talking about uploading
once a day ever since you mentioned it I
think it's helpful advice I like that
you're talking about it not what are you
gonna do you got to do it stop talking
about it guess that's the first step and
I'll start doing it or at least increase
your production definitely my goal now
also you just talking are my favorite
videos because you add a lot of value
love this series
thank you for the love I it up it's a
combination of what I love doing with
what the audience loves too
so this series you know is doing well
it's leading to every video series that
i put up hastily to watch time for the
channel and subscriber growth and if it
doesn't then I kill it unless I'm just
unless is another reason for this series
I like doing it takes up a ton of time
more time than my other series but I
like doing it and it's leaving to watch
time subscriber growth so I keep doing
it so it's great to hear and I'll
continue to experiment with other series
in the future next up Michael Evan for
someone first starting out on YouTube
our social blade and good IQ priceless
value wise do you recommend looking at
the data even early on and what
memberships are worth paying for
Thanks so Michael I have to vid IQ
plug-in installed somehow on my Chrome
and it just shows up with every video I
don't know that I really use it that
much I don't really pay attention to the
data socialblade I'm on almost once a
day I think is part of the daily tabs
that I look at it's good just to know
how the channel is doing you know how
the growth is happening it's easy for
the videos like this to show you know
the growth and compared to other
channels as well I think it's it's
helpful sociable he's also great when
you're doing live streams to hit a
milestone like you've hidden your first
hundred subscribers your four thousand
subscribers you can show it on screaming
your milestones are and just generally
get to know kind of where you're sending
and historically you have Google your
YouTube analytics are which are okay I
just I like being able to see the live
data since the YouTube stuff is like I
don't know why YouTube is days old right
like it's multiple days old before you
can get access for the most part there's
some live stuff but it's really weak so
that allows cumberly sociably to stand
up I'm not a part of a paid program with
either of those two I don't know if they
even have it I guess they do the only
one that I pay for is the one that I
showed you a tube buddy and I started
off on their free program and they have
a lot of free stuff that you can get and
I went to the paid program because of
the split testing it's like what - buddy
the split testing on thumbnails if you
look at any industry any online
marketing you'll see split testing any
market don't even on lines they split
testing like you test one against
another and you see what works is
standard and everything you look at
Facebook guys or Google
or flyers in-store promotions you're
always split testing and YouTube does
not provide you the tools to split test
and so it's a great feature from to
buddy again I think it's about fifty
bucks a month and it just gives you an
edge like if you find the thing that
then pushes your titles or your
thumbnails up by 15-20 percent and you
pile across your whole channel that's
that's right like that's not just for
that one month that's every month that
starts to compound those new people that
came to your channel now are watching
your other videos and then that leads to
other growth and it just makes total
sense
I'm sure at some point YouTube's going
to come up with some tool and in split
testing day by day the way to buddy does
it is not the best scientific way but
it's the only option really right now
that's available so yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't spend listen I wouldn't spend
any money on anything if I'm who's
getting started spend zero I'll put your
time in your energy your hustle use your
phone to film you like don't spend any
money until you start getting some
progress and making money but all three
vidiq you can see if you like it social
blade I like to buddy I like they have
free versions use those to get you
started and as you start making some
money you can see where you want to
invest it another one from Michael
Gary's on vacations entire month he
mentioned this a while back and said
that it's contour we pre-recorded this
month's content is kind of scrambled and
you can definitely tell in the comments
section but the man has worked hard and
he's enjoying his time with us family
got to respect that yeah it's just
priorities like listen Gary's running a
huge company he's got lots of things on
his plate he's got many social media
channels YouTube was not his number one
priority
you know when it's somebody's priority
by where they're spending their time and
Gary does a lot of great work and I'm a
fan and I consume a lot of his content
and he's been a guest on the on the
channel I went on vacation I went on
vacation I was away for over two weeks
we still had videos up every day on the
channel it wasn't just my team rehashing
stuff we had content you can make a plan
you can make it work right it just
wasn't a big enough priority and I don't
blame Gary it's not like Gary's a bad
guy or Gary had a wrong strategy or it
was a wrong move or he shouldn't be
spend time with his family it's all
great just when his team takes over his
channel starts to go down
and it could be getting a better team
having a better strategy putting more
focused effort into it even even
preparing and like in the lead ups to it
having better pre-recorded content like
knowing you're going to go away like his
askgaryvee show why not film eight of
them in advance while he's away or
thirty of them one a day in advance
while he's away why not film that it's
just timing right he didn't make the
time he has a business to run he's got
other things going on he didn't make the
time to do it
you know I filmed for my channel but the
day before I left on my vacation and
then I filmed a couple videos while I
was on vacation it's just different
priorities you know like I had a great
time with my wife on vacation I've
logged a lot of it you guys have seen
the videos coming up now on the channel
and I also care deeply about you guys a
day with no videos on the channel or day
of just like rehashing old stuff I'm not
at that level like I I don't I don't my
standards haven't dropped to that point
I'm uncomfortable with knowing that if I
leave and if my team's gonna take over
the way Gary's team took over and it
crushes a channel I'm not happy with
that I care I care about you guys I care
about the content that goes up and so
it's not that anybody's right or wrong
you just the difference of values and
difference of priorities secretly I was
hoping Gary wouldn't do that because I
wanted the race but Gary's an awesome
guy has great content I'm a fan of the
channel and looking forward to seeing
him be the number two guy to hit a
million subscribers Alexandre next up ah
so much valuing this one Thank You
Evelyn I'm posting a video a day after
watching a video the previous videos
from the series good job Alexandre and
now it's time to step up the game to
make longer quality videos thank you for
the inspiration and for so many
practical devices one who was willing to
listen to have the chance to learn a lot
from this video thank you again ya
length I've talked a little bit about in
previous videos too you want to be
looking at 10 minutes plus it just makes
a huge difference if your videos are 10
minutes plus it skyrockets for whatever
reason YouTube's algorithm they care
about watch time right so you can have a
ton of people watch a 1 minute long
video but on almost every channel and
I've shown you guys in previous episodes
go to the Grant Cardone episode you'll
see the videos that were really short 1
minute long 2 minutes long you don't
the views they don't get the watch time
YouTube downgrades them they don't want
short content then you can have like
you'll say heaven Hey look at the
trending tab there'll be some video that
is super short in 30 seconds long you
can have one or two exceptions right
there's always one or two that break
through that are outside the norm but
when I'm giving you advice it works
consistently like you want to bet on
making an amazing 1 minute long video
and just hope that it takes off you're
gonna fail a ton or if you're making
consistent 10 minute plus videos it's
just what YouTube wants like it's just
making it easier for you yes it's harder
to make quality content at 10 minutes
plus but it's making easier for you to
get known like I want people to see your
message when people subscribe to your
channel I want people to buy your
products from people to be attached to
the stuff you're creating and it just is
so much easier when you're playing to
YouTube's algorithm you could pass the
people again who have more talent in you
because you just that you understand the
game more because you're watching the
video or you're consuming other YouTube
content where you're getting education
ten minutes plus a video a day ten
minutes plus you can do it playing for
it you may not be ready now playing for
put it in you could do it Devon I love
these videos I would have never checked
my analytics if it wasn't with a series
I'm glad it helps and I'm not the most
data-driven analytics nerd guy out there
like there's channels where every little
thing is nitpicked and analyzed and
people were better at it than me but to
never look at your analytics you're
missing opportunities because a lot of
the like everything else of all the
analytics is 80/20 right a lot of even
just looking at what I showed you in
this video about where's your traffic
coming from if it's the related videos
as opposed to search just knowing that
then that allows you to make better
thumbnails and titles even if that's all
you looked at and you never went back to
it that's already massive value that you
can add to your channel so there's a lot
of little tweaks like that you can see
significant improvements with and then
if you want to get into the nitty-gritty
and go for that final twenty percent
that's a choice
next up Sharif my only question in terms
of Evans mission is whether there are a
billion entrepreneurs out there right
now it's possible there isn't but there
will be in the not-too-distant future
it's not super related to this video
topic but the point of that big goal the
point of me wanting to help a billion
entrepreneurs is just to have a big goal
to have a lifelong mission like I don't
care about tracking the goal I'm not
in YouTube views or subscribers like if
we're ready at how many how many we have
200 million views something like that
like if I use as I met check I'm almost
there right that's that's that sucks I
don't want to hit my lifetime goal I
want I need that I need to get there a
little slower right like I need to have
a bigger impact I guess it's just more
to have something that shapes my
decisions so going to YouTube as an
example allows me to impact a lot of
people writing my first book and on my
second book allows me to reach a lot of
people have an impact it's why I'm not a
one-on-one business coach because yes I
can have a deep impact with the people
that I help but it doesn't really help
my mission of being with the help of
billion entrepreneurs and so it just
shapes my decisions as to am I playing a
big enough game like how do I play a
bigger game how do I reach more people
how do I have a bigger impact whether or
not I ever hit a billion entrepreneurs
doesn't really matter so I don't really
track and that there's no metric I don't
even care if there's a billion
entrepreneurs out there right none of
those things matter it's about me doing
work that can reach the widest possible
audience in a really impactful way next
passion project I like this video even
before seeing this video I appreciate
the love that's what you want to get to
with your audience too right I mean I
know there's a core hardcore group of
people who love my videos and will just
automatically watch them and
automatically like them incoming and I
always appreciate that I feel like I
want to earn every view that comes in
but you want that for your channel too
right like will people automatically
like the video before they even watch
what's in it because you've just
developed this history and reputation
and it goes back to having a thumbnail
that's recognizable if you have a
thumbnail in the title that's totally
different people may not even know that
that's your video and so they never
watch it and you're losing out on that
audience to help spread the message for
you Sharif's arora LOL to evans shut
down on those comments that's awesome i
don't remember what my shut down was but
i'm glad you liked it I try not to slam
people but if we can make a point I
guess that helps hopefully like it's all
it's all would love trying to help you
guys and sometimes we have to crush the
lone in beliefs but it's never personal
it's not like those are bad people and
my goal is never to come on and shut
people down it's why I love the Mark
Cuban like I'm so glad that the happy
Mark Cuban thumbnail did better than the
yelling Mark Cuban video I just want to
be able to spread more positivity more
believe
I want to said more believe then then
anger and yelling in attack in hatred so
anyway I'm glad that I help next a leox
phishing TV Evan if I make all my videos
ten minutes plus I could only post three
to four days a week if I include three
to four minutes videos I can post daily
what to do that is a tough question
if it were me so you're basically
valuing how long like length of a video
versus upload frequency if I had to pick
between doing three to four ten minute
long videos that were quality or weekly
three to four minute videos like once a
week I would go with a three to four
10-minute videos I think three to four
is enough of a frequency to get
triggered by the algorithm in the ten
minute versus the three to four minute
will make a big difference it's it's
hard it's hard to get a three minute
video ranked and get people clicking on
it just doesn't generate enough watch
time and so YouTube really downgrades it
and it's a great point because maybe I
haven't talked enough about video length
in this series maybe next week I'll do
it but I mean I did it or next month I
did it with Grant Cardone so you can
check that one out but I mean ideally
you want both right so if you're making
three to four videos that are ten
minutes long three two videos a week
that are ten minutes long we want to we
want to work our way up like hopefully
you start making some money you start
monetizing you start you know selling
some deals that you can expand your your
team and get to seven days a week or 14
days a week right to a day but if I had
to pick one over the other I would say
if you were dropping below once a week
then you're really going to get hit I
think hard by the algorithm but a three
to four minute video is also really
rough to get ranked so that would be my
advice I don't know that I have good
tests to be able to show you but every
time I've seen a video go up with that
it's three to four minutes long it just
it just massively underperforms if you
compared to a 10 minute long plus video
so that's my advice but really endgame
endgame bro we're going both okay
10 minute long plus seven days a week
subconscious sketches wait a sec
Kevin you say you were sick stop doing
your wim HOF breathing or what a
glorious content by the way I really dig
the data in comparison to guarantee I'm
rooting for you thank you for the love
yeah I need to be a little more
consistent the wim HOF it's easy when
you're feeling really great so I've been
sick once really badly since I started I
had a one-day fever when I was at Tony
Robbins event and then I got sick for a
couple days I guess last month when I
made the video that's still pretty good
for my track record considering like
we're in October and I've only been sick
once all year when I would be getting
sick like every two weeks before that's
pretty good but yeah I need to be more
consistent it's easy when things are
going well to just leave it and then if
you leave it for too long then those old
things come back so I've been pretty
good though since I've been since I got
that like reminder since I got punched
in the face on that one I've been pretty
good and still haven't been sick yet so
fingers crossed for a good winter thank
you for the love next up Lisa I am hey
Evan you should feel really good about
your channel and what you're doing to
inspire motivate new young and old
entrepreneur such as myself after
watching meeting your videos I decided
today is the day no more excuses I've
been making unique products and unique
picture frames over 15 years and I'm
told numerous times to get started thank
you for having these videos to keep me
motivated sometimes videos will do more
for me than the actual people around me
lol well thank you for the love Lisa
congratulations on starting your
business that's really cool I love
seeing people take that first step and
the first step is our scariest and it's
the hardest you take that first step
then you take the next one the next one
as long as you continue that positive
momentum you'll do you'll do great
I'm excited to see where you take this I
agree that a lot of people in our lives
are not super supportive you know they
don't know how to push us they don't
know how to motivate us they may Dave if
you're lucky they may be empathetic and
just try to help understand you and if
you're unlucky you got people telling
you you're never gonna make it and how
much you suck and you should just go get
a job so I'm glad that the videos like
your environment really matters and if
my videos are part of that environment
that helps you daily it means just a ton
to me I do feel really good about my
channel I feel really good about my
channel and I think it needs a ton of
work you know it's like both sides I
love my channel I think it's the best
thing on the Internet and it needs to
get way way way way way way better to
get to where I want to go like if I want
to hit tell me 10 million subscribers
next year
it's not gonna happen do what I'm doing
right now and it's easy to coast its
head like looks and look we're crushing
we're first one the million this is
great doing so much good but I know I
could do better and I need to find the
path to get better and maybe you guys
will give me some suggestions that and
do that too next up Liliana who cares
about subscribers I care about the
practical content that the YouTube
provides I love ty Lopez because of that
why is the worried about what others are
all doing so I'm not worried I think a
couple things off of this first why you
care about YouTube subscribers is you're
an entrepreneur you need to have an
audience right you're trying to get
people to sell you to buy your product
buy your service to believe in your
message to buy your book whatever it is
if it's just a hobby and you don't care
if anybody watches it like you want to
feel like the work you're doing is
meaningful and so subscribers are
somebody's vote to say hey your content
is meaningful it means a lot to me like
if you love practical stuff then you're
gonna subscribe to the channels where
you're getting practical information and
then that person knows hey Lilliana
likes this stuff people are liking my
practical information I'm going to
create more of it right but my
subscribers have allowed me to create
more content it's allowed me to build on
a team it's not me to build a business
or on YouTube and so getting a
subscriber itself is meaningless as a
number right like if you just buying
subscribers that doesn't help you but if
those subscribers are real people who
then vote with their attention that then
you can use that to build a business
around that helps everybody build and
grow it helps my business girl helps you
make more content hopefully you guys
watching it you're now building and
growing your businesses and so it helps
all boats rise in terms of comparing to
other people one I think you can look to
other people to get ideas to get
inspiration to get some some creative
new things they might be able to do for
your channel and to it's a good kind of
benchmark to see right tie is a special
case as I mentioned you know he builds
his business mostly to advertising I
don't I don't play the advertising game
so I don't just definitely model there
he's built a great business around it
it's not about trashing tie or trashing
Gary Vee or thrashing Oprah or any the
people that I profile on the channel
it's
just to help show what people are doing
their models how they're having success
how I think people might be able to
improve based off my history and
hopefully you use that you like
practical information hopefully the
practical information in the video that
then you can use to help build your
channel and so if you interpret this
just as a who's better than Who and
slugfest to win that's not the intention
and I've only said positive things about
the people who who are profiled and
gives them some suggestions so hopefully
you can see that for what it is and use
the information to help you build your
business
next up Edie I'm so excited for ever and
reaching is million subscriber goal I'm
waiting for Evan is a win for me and a
win for entrepreneurship thank you for
the love I D a millions coming soon I
don't know what I'm gonna do a a bunch
of people I'm asking for a live stream
so I'm probably gonna try to do a live
stream when we hit a million I'm open to
ideas what we should do on the live
stream again it just depends like if I'm
in the country if I have a meeting you
know you never know when you're gonna
cross a certain milestone so I've done
it for some and not done it for others
most of them I haven't done and again
celebrating is not really part of what I
normally do so this is a good reminder
that we've gotta take a break and
celebrate and hopefully we'll have a
chance to be able to do it in a million
and again your feedback I'd love it in
the comments and how to what we should
do this hello break next up Eric draws I
don't think Gary is actually on YouTube
to have the most followers because his
revenue comes from deals with big
businesses but I think he wants obscure
briefs nonetheless that being said I
admire your hustle and I hope you get
the numbers you want and agree with
August being productive because I
haven't hustled as much as I have this
month and this video gives me the
motivation to kick August in the face I
love that and take my success I work in
as hard as I ever have I'm just taking a
meal break to leave this comment to let
you know you're a big influence on me
yeah awesome listen guys I want to make
this clear for everybody watching
YouTube is not the primary business I
don't think for for most of the people
that I'm covering right like it's not my
primary business is not Gary's primary
business not Grant's primary business
YouTube itself is just a path to get an
audience and when I profile guys like
Eric Thomas before I think he was the
first one or the second one that I did
he has a great business and it started
on YouTube and is expanded beyond it I'm
not showing you how to build a business
around YouTube that's not the point of
this series right maybe that's a
continuation of the series this is how
to get subscribers because from
subscribers you can build a business
right from subscribers a lot of things
can happen for you and so if I'm looking
at Eric's channel or Gary's channel or
Ty's channel or Patrick's channel it's
just looking at what people are doing
what you can learn from them my advice
that I would give to them and just
sharing the strategy that I've learned
to help me get to almost a million and
documenting the journey to get to a
million hopefully you guys find value
from that but it's not to say that this
is the best model and and absolutely
everybody has other other businesses
other projects that they're working on
but the point of the series like it's
called how to get to 1 million
subscribers I'm just trying to help you
guys get there faster
next up Charles kind of weird seen Ty's
subs flatten out I for one unsubscribe
because the content decrease in sales
pitch is tripled feel Gary's going to
sling in September in November it'll be
closed between you two
yeah again like pies got a really
interesting business model if you like
studying business models it's worth
checking out how he did it because he's
a really unique youtuber everybody knows
Thai whether whether you love him or
hate him everybody's seen those car
commercials you know you're in my garage
everybody knows that whether people love
it and are making fun of them you know
who he is and he built the business in
the back of it so there's something to
learn from it not many people have
follow up in his footsteps like I can't
say anybody that I know that I've seen
that much advertising come out of and so
maybe that was a moment in time maybe
that models disappeared like he's not
continuing with it now so maybe he you
know he can't find a way to continue
that stream or maybe he's you know got
all the business he wants doesn't want
to continue growing maybe he's focused
somewhere else who knows maybe he's all
about Instagram and not about YouTube
anymore
I don't know but it's an interesting
case to be able to see him grow but when
you build a business any business you
build a business off of advertising and
then you stop advertising your business
is gonna start to go down and so that's
the case with Ty he's got content
whether you think it's sales pitchy or
not I don't really watch his stuff so I
couldn't tell you but I still have
really cool like if you ever want to try
to grow something through advertising
you need to look at Ty's history and see
how he did it because that's great
lessons for your business for Gary sling
in September in November I hope
so man I'm really hoping like Gary comes
out and crushes and has some insane plan
for October and and it's getting close
it's just it's gonna be really hard it's
gonna be really hard
short of doing a big ad campaign or
getting some major thing happened it's
gonna be hard to do it but I'm rooting
for him I wanted to be a close race and
I wouldn't mind losing like I love the
back-to-back I don't mind being number
two I don't mind losing that race
because it's fun to see the climb next
up chart you're Dre thanks right to my
question about video length and thanks
for the shout out here's another
question do you know what would happen
if you upload the same video natively to
both YouTube buying a Facebook would
have the same effect as posting the same
blog post in multiple sites would on
your SEO doing this with blog posts will
quickly kill the number of people Google
sends to your blog thanks Evan PS
started posting videos more frequently
it's already paying off on my channel I
can only do two three a week so far but
even that is already helping myself to
go up thanks for the helpful advice I'm
a big fan of marketing within the
platform that you're working on I think
you just have a lot more results I think
if your goal is to drive traffic to your
website I wouldn't be worried too much
about building up Facebook or YouTube as
a platform I've been looking at how do I
build more content on my website and try
to win that game through SEO and through
leveraging other people's network so if
you're looking at influencers or you're
looking at advertising to drive traffic
to your website I think if you're
looking at a YouTube strategy or a
Facebook strategy you're trying to win
in that game so the point of having a
youtube channel is to build up an
audience within YouTube and then convert
and market to the people on YouTube not
trying to get them to come visit your
website and hopefully be a subscriber
there but to convert within the YouTube
platform same thing for Facebook like I
don't I don't think it works as well to
try to get a facebook strategy to then
try to build a YouTube audience or to
try to build a website audience if I was
building Facebook strong I'd be looking
at Facebook and try to convert within
Facebook and so if my goal was SEO for
my website I think there's a lot better
ways you can use that time money and
energy then YouTube I don't think
YouTube is your winning strategy I think
if you want to win at YouTube you have
to care about building a subscriber base
building a loyal audience there
and then converting those people into
its own final it's not about converting
website sales its converting now that
YouTube sales I think if you look at it
like that you'll have a lot more success
if you look at it as just trying to
build your SEO I think it's a I think
there's other things you can do I think
it's a losing strategy we're gonna end
it there it's been a lot of fun it's
been tons of questions my boys are
starting to get dry I'm gonna have some
water thank you guys for all the love
and support along this journey it's been
an awesome ride it's great like the
challenge for me as I love answering
your questions so much I could be here
all day but then I don't get my other
work done making other videos for you
guys so it's a nice mix to have yeah let
me know what you think share your
thoughts your feedback suggestions we're
gonna have one or two more videos in
this series and then that's the end of
it if there's a topic you'd like me to
cover in another episode let me know in
the comments if you have suggestions for
what you want to see on the million live
stream hopefully we can get that to
happen again leave that in the comments
I really appreciate the love and support
I hope you go out and use this knowledge
to help build your YouTube audiences so
you can spread your message have a big
impact that's why I do what I do and I
hope you leverage that to expand your
business as well thank you guys again
for the love I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whenever your one word is
I'm on my trampoline much love guys I'll
see you soon